the very first game that I play was  Missile Command in the arcade and I was  completely blown away by it space  invaders I remember the early Scott  Adams adventure games on my TI 99 for a  it was mind-blowing to see that somebody  could control what was going on a screen  of my dad brought home a Sears pong  station for our television or with a  little twist controller and a button I  don't know what year it was that it was  pizza hut and it was space invaders and  I got hooked let those who would destroy  us step into the light  the world is tearing itself apart hey oz  has left its mark upon me  I am hunted for the power I wield  you will write I will die first